[Musique]
tu m'envoies des playlists qui vont voir
tourner trouve tout à moi j'étais
incarner tout en excluant un départ de
l'épreuve gmarket chantre de la foux
deux battants que c'est beaucoup mieux
accueilli une pierre
une paire est bien ok mais pas n'importe
laquelle tout quartz quartz ouais c'est
par exemple celle là ouais c'est bien
dormir tu as posé à côté de toi
dort comme un bébé comme un bébé ouais
alors je me réveille toutes les deux
heures pour changer les couches peut
verser tout comme envieux ce qu'il va
faire à ta pas de bière du nid au genre
si je la pose à côté de mon rib les
héros il augmente
les
défauts y croire [ __ ] faut croire aux
réticences de le perdre sans déconner ya
des vrais trucs dedans c'est qu'est ce
tu fais quand à la migraine un
non sens j'ai testé la menthe poivrée
c'est le monde qui s'en vont la tuer
dans l'étape on est battu c'est quoi
j'ai arrêté ça me donne envie de fumer
le chichon
tarifs et la maison j'ai même la fait
pas de livret a mais tu déconnes tu vois
à la fibre les ondes tout ça c'est nul
je procède bien tu la pause pour ta tête
comme ça
du torticolis ouais j'aime bien forcé
hockey du coup du conte du bleu ou là où
c'est très rôdée internet arrête avec
cette question de merde là pourquoi tu
fais genre tu t'intéresses à la pose du
gazon décrit chien avec un v non
citadine pas mieux répondre à déjà vue
et relâché avec m excuse moi
d'où le nom parle sérieusement mon
bâtiment l effet en pierre d'accord ou
pas pourquoi est-ce que ça m'empêche pas
d'abord demander la tête et au ventre
alors qu'il est en pierre c'est du
calcaire bordel ça n'a rien à voir
excuse moi ouais d'accord tu passais
bien au van damme
ressent la pierre bardet ouais ouais
tiens mes yeux change
[Musique]
car ce à quoi je sens qu'elle perde mon
nom wii continue concentre toi j'avoue
je commence à sentir un truc là là j'ai
faim de 10 j'ai pas mangé toute la
journée
j'aime bien pour ça
en sus la pierre
[Musique]